en este vídeo quiero simplificar la
misma expresión que hicimos hace un par
de vídeos con división sintética pero
ahora con división larga con división
tradicional espero mostrarte en el
camino porque la división sintética y la
división larga nos dan el mismo
resultado va entonces voy a empezar
haciendo la división larga y poco a poco
vamos viendo las las conexiones entonces
lo primero que tenemos que hacer en
división larga es observar los términos
de mayor grado este x y este 3x al cubo
y nos tenemos que preguntar cuántas
veces cabe x en 3x al cubo pues justo
cabe 3x cuadrada a veces verdad 3 x al
cubo entre x es igual a 3 x al cuadrado
ya desde aquí se empiezan a ver
conexiones con la división sintética
este 3x al cuadrado corresponde a este 3
de acá si entonces éste corresponde a
este de acá y porque corresponde a eso
porque siempre nos va a dar lo mismo o
sea de este lado como que bajamos el 3
así sin pensarlo y aquí si tuvimos que
pensarlo bueno pues nos da lo mismo por
lo que le pedimos al denominador en la
división que tenía que ver con que solo
era una equis no podíamos tener x al
cuadrado 17 x 23 x cúbica tenía que ser
una x así sencillita y por lo tanto
cuando nos preguntamos cuántas veces
cabeza x en este término vamos a tener
el mismo coeficiente y aquí vamos a
tener un grado menor que este 3x cúbica
entonces aparece este 3x cuadrada que
corresponde con este 3 que también
corresponde a x cuadrada vale bueno
vamos a seguir entonces ahora en
división sintética tenemos que
multiplicar 3x cuadrada por esto de acá
3 x cuadrada x x es igual a 3 x cúbica
déjame ponerlo en color blanco 3 x
cúbica y luego 3 x cuadrada x 4 es igual
a 12 x cuadrada entonces aquí le pongo
12 x cuadrada déjame poner esta línea y
lo que tenemos que hacer es restar
entonces aquí le pongo menos aquí le
pongo menos estos dos se cancelan y aquí
restamos 4 x cuadrada menos 12 x
cuadrada y aquí nos quedaría
en color verde nos quedaría menos 8 x
cuadrado
entonces vamos teniendo cada vez más
analogías observan este menos 8 x
cuadrada tiene un poco que ver con este
menos 8 todavía no totalmente porque
este menos 8 corresponde a un término
lineal pero aquí su término cuadrática
sin embargo de donde salió pues b salió
de restar 4 con menos 12 y este menos 12
salió de multiplicar 3 con 4 hicimos 3
por 4 12 y luego restamos es exactamente
lo mismo que estamos haciendo acá este 3
lo multiplicamos por cuatro que nos da
12 y luego lo restamos por eso cambiamos
el signo al inicio para no tener que
hacer pues las restas a cada rato sino
acordarse bueno ya incluir en el
numerito que estamos restando entonces
ok este 8 tiene que ver con este 8 cómo
le hacemos para que de adeveras
corresponda a un 8 lineal pues
bajamos el menos 2 x 2 x y ahora nos
preguntamos cuántas veces cabe x en
menos 8 x cuadrada ah pues ahora si cabe
menos 8 x veces menos 8 x veces y una
vez más osea obtuvimos el mismo
coeficiente aquí menos 8 y menos 8
porque estamos pidiendo que aquí sea una
equis solita va entonces aquí tenemos
menos 8x que corresponde corresponde
justamente a este término de acá a esta
x vamos a seguir
entonces ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es multiplicar menos 8x por esta
expresión no voy a poner en color blanco
menos 8 x x x es menos 8 x cuadrado
menos 8 x cuadrada menos 8 x x 4 es
igual a
voy a poner en color rosa 32 x bueno
menos 32 x restamos y al restar esto se
cancela menos 2 x menos 32 x bueno menos
menos 32 x verdad porque aquí hay que
sumar nos da igual a 30 30 x lo pongo
aquí 30 x y ve acá hicimos lo mismo o
sea multiplicamos menos 8 por 4 y ahora
lo restamos pero aquí estamos
multiplicando menos 8 x menos 4 y
sumamos es exactamente lo mismo y de ahí
sale ese 30 ahora este 30 es el término
constante el que corresponde a x a la 0
y para que salga de este lado tenemos
que preguntarnos ahora déjame poner este
menos 1 para preguntarnos cuántas veces
cabe x en 30 x y cabe 30 veces entonces
lo voy a poner por aquí arriba lo voy a
poner más
30 ahora sí este 30 es este 30 aquí ya
aparece el término constante
multiplicamos 30 por equis es 30 x 30
por 4 es 120 más de 120 kva y restamos
aquí restamos se cancela y aquí menos 1
menos aquí tengo que ser menos porque
estamos restando que hace menos 121
entonces se le pongo aquí menos 121 y
ahora si esté menos 121 es el mismo que
esté menos 121 porque es el residuo de
lo que queda entonces de ahí se ven
todas las ideas de por qué es
exactamente lo mismo hacer la división
larga que la división sintética y
básicamente en resumen lo que está
sucediendo es que suponer que está x
está solita nos permite ir copiando los
coeficientes y simplemente como ir
restando lo que tenemos que restar y
todo sale igualito vale entonces en el
fondo la división larga y la división
sintética están haciendo exactamente lo
mismo solo que la división sintética
pues es un poco más corta
más sencilla y también ocupa menos
espacio